[Music]
we've got the explosive search dog teams
out with us and we're just clearing
streets and making sure it's is safe
it's possible for the tourists and
people visiting with just 29 days to go
in Windsor it's all hands and Tails on
deck putting security checks in place
well the search teams they will
regularly empty the drains make sure
there's nothing of a criminal nature
that are to be discarded or deliberately
put in there expect security to be
especially heightened when Harry and
Megan recreate this William and Kate
moment riding through the crowds in an
open carriage after their I Do's it's
estimated that tens of thousands of
people will be there to witness this
historic union
[Music]
she's an American she's an actress she's
gasp older I'm touching my pearls she's
like three years older which as you know
it's nothing and she's biracial and the
royal family is like this is great
because everybody is happy for Harry
tonight Gayle King helps Megan mania go
primetime when Megan Markel American
princess
airs on CBS Megan Markel will indeed
become Her Royal Highness
when she walks down the aisle here at
st. George's Chapel we were actually
inside the church and when you're inside
this chapel it really does feel like a
very intimate setting with stained glass
windows appears all of it it's a
beautiful beautiful sacred space the
special also features Megan sorority
sisters from Northwestern University
they discussed the future royal in her
college days she's the total package and
smart she's gonna be a princess and I'm
trying to kind of go I said she's
actually marrying a prince a real one
and I'm driving to Costco no bitterness
there yeah and on wedding day May 19th
to
like the blending of CBS Morning News
and Entertainment Tonight and we're
gonna be live for six friggin hours so I
know he's a very good talker and this
will be the first time that Kevin and
I've stepped out as a couple I wonder
what he's gonna wear Gail I'm gonna wear
a big fat smile on my face because I'm
gonna be with you
[Music]